so what should we do when they turn our
drone into goo
the Pentagon is blaming Russian fighter
jets for causing a U.S drone to crash
into the Black Sea sorry person of color
see
on Tuesday
worse the Drone was shot down just two
days after its warranty expired from
Radio Shack
Putin denied responsibility so quickly
he's been made in honorary Clinton
[Applause]
speaking of Russia Ron DeSantis is
getting pushed back from fellow righties
for insinuating that further U.S
involvement in the war in Ukraine is not
vital to our national interest unless
you think our national interest is
starting world war three but at this
point with so much already invested in
Ukraine with drug support is easier said
than done I just came up with that
maybe as president DeSantis might be
able to do what no Biden can do pull out
in time
a ball
ah
KT applauding that one well meanwhile
the pentagon's focus on more important
stuff aliens and not the ones
complaining about our free food and
hotel rooms the top official says they
could be visiting our solar system in a
big Mothership mother and releasing
probes near Earth which might explain
that weird soreness I feel when I sit
down
this as the Navy plans to increase
climate spending almost 40 percent in
2024. they're asking Congress for 400
million dollars for electric vehicles
and solar microgrids because nothing
inspires fear like a battleship with an
extension cord
I can see it now we can't go to war Mr
President someone forgot to charge up
our aircraft carriers
KT there's a lot of parts to this uh
segment so uh I don't know which topic
you want to hone in on personally I
don't think the Drone getting close to
our plane or the vice versa is that big
of a deal yeah I mean what's the Black
Sea anyway it's almost kind of Russia
international water so yeah a deal but
it's not a big deal yeah DeSantis is
right when he talks about vital National
emphasis their difference there's vital
national interests for which we would go
to war and there are interests and
national interests for which we might
try to affect the outcome but we don't
necessarily send in the Marines DeSantis
was right to say this is not in our
Vital national interests however you
want to stop the Ukraine war in about
six months okay here's the answer yes
okay here's the answer number one stop
the war on American fossil fuels so that
American oil producers and gas natural
gas producers start pumping it out we
become Not Just Energy independent we
become energy dominant that's the word
and that drives the price of oil natural
gas down Russia's bankrupt within six
months because it requires all of that
that's how it's paying for the war is
the high price of oil and gas within six
months Russia's bankrupt you force them
to the negotiating table you find a deal
and then Ukraine wins the piece because
five years after the fighting stops
Ukraine is a fully integrated economy
into Europe and what's Russia low gas
prices is bankrupt a war that it didn't
win is a pariah state so Russia's finito
well you know that sounds too easy
great thing about uh the five viewers
that a lot of them don't watch the show
so I'm going to just say what you said
tomorrow
and I'm going to call it the Gutfeld
Doctrine Tom
steal it outright no one will think and
think that I stole it from oh I like it
I like it do you do you agree that could
it be that simple I don't know if it is
Greg I was going to talk about the
aliens yes please do I know you hate
them yeah no I don't believe in aliens
because I believe in Jesus and I feel
like he would have mentioned the aliens
I think he would have said something
I mean I don't think he would have said
what planet they are on but I think he
would have mentioned he would be like I
I I will come again in glory to judge
the living and the dead and I'll try to
get here before the spaceman you know I
think he would have mentioned that they
were you know maybe he didn't want to
spoil the surprise I mean no that's a
possibility but I okay what if Jesus
was an alien
can I say that no
is that sacrilege I think yeah that
would if anything is maybe that's that's
it
no but I mean it's like if you have if
you have a more Universal idea of the
afterlife the afterlife could be but see
this is the thing about Doctrine and you
believe it you believe it a certain way
but it could be you know you could be
living a simulation you don't know I
mean it could be you know anything yeah
you like that simulation thing I'm not
that into that I know I know yeah
doesn't have an interesting reading yes
as Catholicism let's move on from this
very awkward religious moment
Kat do you want to cover uh uh aliens or
drones or DeSantis or climate funding
there's a lot of options there yeah
there's a lot of options uh the climate
funding actually concerns me less than
the amount of funding uh the military
budget that Biden is demanding is either
the largest in peace time or the largest
in history period depending on who you
ask and how they look at those numbers
look at inflation he's actually cutting
defense spending but we're supposedly
not at War and not thinking about going
to war and I just don't buy it I just
don't buy it I have some concern about
it I think there's a lot of distraction
of if anybody asks any questions about
this war there's a lot of pylon of well
this person a Russian operative when
really you have many legitimate reasons
to question this and you should question
most things but to question this in
particular when you look at history and
also when you look at the present and
it's it's just that kind of catch-all
term when anyone dares to do it that
makes me want to question you're in
Putin's pocket see like that yeah no I
was just saying that's what they say
yeah I don't say you're important
puppet and then like let me apologize
yeah and then like a bunch of other
people be like oh got him and it's like
who are these people what do you do
spend two weeks in Putin's pocket and
they call you Putin you're in Putin's
pocket all right Douglas
thoughts on Ukraine I'm sure you have
some you went there yeah so recently um
uh I'm more interested in the aliens
okay let's go with the aliens well
because you know that that cartoon we
all had when we were growing up where
the uh like little man like antenna like
that get out of a spaceship and they
they come to a human being and they say
take us to your leader it feels to me
like that we're close to that point and
that when we introduce them to the
president they're gonna say
this is
you know
I know Trump would be great with the
aliens come on you guys got to try the
steaks safe he'd say we fell in love we
fell in love we fell in love by the way
best aliens they're the best aliens ever
no wall no wall for these aliens
right you know anyway
that's not even a good impression
I don't try
Story of My Life hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else